yes legit I didn't call this so the
review embargo is up for Wonder Woman
and the reviews are good they're really
good they're great and that is a good
thing I think that might come as a
surprise to some people who remember my
incredibly angry
Randy video about how I wanted the DCE
you to fail however if you actually go
back and watch it which I encourage you
to do I wouldn't mind the extra views at
about two minute mark I do say that if
Wonder Woman is great it might alter my
opinion but I gave my thoughts at that
time and I still stand by those thoughts
at the time that I have them you know
what I'm CUBAN I'm allowed to have my
opinions changed and I did say in that
video that if Wonder Woman is great I
will go see it I made the assumption I
was not going to go see it because at
that point in time I didn't see in my
head any scenario in which that movie
was going to be great I figured the best
was going to be was decent better than
BBS or Suicide Squad and for me that
wasn't going to be good enough I wanted
overwhelming just this is a terrific
movie not just in comparison to what the
DC EU has been but in of itself it's
great go see it and that that appears to
be the consensus now I personally acted
on the scoring have not seen the movie
yet I do intend to I do intend to do a
review but I haven't seen it yet but
even if I don't like it that is not
going to impact anything I'm going to
say here because I want to talk about
how this may or may not affect the DCE
you going forward we got to start with
some numbers though now the Rotten
Tomatoes score at the time of this
recording is still hovering in the low
90s now as more reviews come in odds are
that might go down a little bit more
that's not a guarantee I expect it to
settle either in the very high eighties
of the very low 90s which is still
really good even if it dips under 90%
that is really good I don't want to
focus too much on the Rotten Tomatoes
percentage though I would rather talk
about the Rotten Tomatoes average score
because the problem with a percentage
and people who know enough of our own
Tomatoes understand it is
gives you a broad stroke but a 90 you
know something percent approval rating
doesn't me like it's 97 percent or
whatever of the best movie ever it just
said that most of the reviewers and you
know that percentage of reviewers had a
more positives than negatives where
things get dicey is Rotten Tomatoes has
to assign a positive or negative to what
sometimes can be a very split review if
somebody's really have two minds that if
you read the reviews kind of on the
fence Rotten Tomatoes has to decide to
recount this bother do we have this
negative and that can end up stealing
results in either direction so I want to
scrap the percentage and that rating so
forget it
let's talk average so right now at the
time of this recording what elements is
sitting at a 7.6 average score now in
have itself if you aren't used to
looking at the average score that may
not sound that great that's about a see
if you were to put it into a school
grading system but let's do a little bit
of comparison the best rated DC EU was
Man of Steel that clock end at a 6.2
Batman V Superman Lane but 4.9 Suicide
Squad got 4.7 so this is already head
and shoulders much better than anything
that the DC EU has put out so let's
compare it to some other stuff that has
come out if we want to go by just what
causes here Logan had a 7.9 guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 had a 7.8 so that I
think gives you a slightly more
realistic metric now that's not you know
depending on tone those might not be
accurate things to compare to but let's
just looking at score this is good this
is very good this is up there with
movies that have come out this year that
have been very successful and pretty
well received by both critics and
audiences so this is all good stuff and
I am legitimately happy about this I
know I have my whole rant about how I
wanted the whole DC EU to fail but you
need to remember the reason I wanted it
to fail was because I saw no possible
way that it was ever going to get good
and I just wanted it to crash now so
that we could start over and build
something better what we're seeing right
now with these reviews is the outcome
that I didn't dare to dream was possible
this is great I'm ecstatic so the
question now becomes can
save the DCE you short answer no not by
yourself but maybe it can get things
pushed in the correct direction a lot of
us going to come down to how it does at
the box office though so let's take a
quick look at those numbers right now
it's on track to do 175 million in its
international on its opening weekend
because it's opening in US and
international at the same time now that
sounds ready to go but I kind of want to
narrow the focus to just talk domestic
just so it because it makes for an
easier point of comparison so
domestically it's on track right now for
a seventy-five million dollar opening
weekend now ACA may come in above that
it may come in after that but for right
now let's just treat the estimates as
the most likely and move forward 75
million is respectable it's pretty good
for a blockbuster tentpole superhero
movie based on one of the best-known
superhero characters it sounds a little
on the weak side though I mean guardians
of the galaxy 2 did about twice that but
as soon as I check that number I also
realize that's not a fair comparison
because that's a sequel to an already
established franchise so I think how
more fair comparison might be the first
guardians of the galaxy which was a more
of an unknown property did 93 million
domestically as opening weekend or more
recently than that dr. strange again
first entry in that particular franchise
while still being part of a bigger
shared universe that did 85 million
domestic on its opening weekend so
Wonder Woman he is coming a little bit
behind those now it's still in that
ballpark so it's playing a nightclub but
it is a little bit behind until you
really start looking at the context and
realize how much this thing is fighting
against first of all it's fighting
against the stigma against the DC EU
itself now you may love the DCU movies
if you do great I am happy for you I'm
glad you got enjoyment but even if you
like this stuff even if you don't like
the fact that a lot of people care or
not like it you can't argue with the
fact that these films have been divisive
at best and they haven't been
universally loved so this thing getting
that kind of critical praise is great
but in terms of the opening weekend box
office the movie is kind of heard it's
got to pull against a stigma from
audiences who have gotten possibly up to
three movies that they didn't like and
then you add to that the additional
stigma against female lead Kenpo style
Fran
myself I mean we don't really have a ton
of points of comparison for this that
how uncommon this is and most of the
times you can think of it it's been a
disaster I mean in terms of superheroes
Catwoman Elektra a super girl uh but if
you want to look at something more
recently last year we had the female
lead ghostbusters now I'm not saying
that the fact that these were wind were
why these movies failed or underperform
a lot of them have a lot of problems
that completely aside from that but it
still creates a stigma it creates this
idea that superhero led movies aren't
good and don't make money so it's got to
fight against that too so when you
factor that context in a seventy-five
million dollar opening is pretty solid
what's really going to make or break
this thing though is whether or not it
has legs so this thing needs to keep
strong in the following weekend and not
have a massive drop-off because a
massive drop-off I mean a big opening
week especially if you win the opening
weekend that sounds good and all but if
it has a massive drop-off after that
that's still a problem
Aryan Covenant had a 71 percent drop-off
from its premiere weekend to this past
one what a woman can't afford to take
that kind of hit Batman V Superman
another example that had a 69% drop off
from its first weekend to its next one
now that one even though ultimately it
did come shy of what the projection
sport wore it could still afford that
hit because this opening weekend was so
huge it was a two hundred million dollar
plus opening weekend so even though it
took a very big hit the next weekend it
was still a big enough number that it
added up when you're opening at 75
million you need legs you've got to keep
going strong and the reviews are
probably going to go a good way towards
ensuring that that happens it doesn't
guarantee it but it certainly helps
because generally the opening we get is
the opening weekend people who want to
see it right away are going to see it
right away regardless of what the
critics say but people who are rushing
to see it out the first weekend are
deciding a week two three weeks later do
I want to see this they are more likely
to be affected by the critical reviews
going oh well there's this new thing out
but there was Wonder Woman and everyone
said that was great
I'll go see that so the critical reviews
could really help this thing have the
legs that it needs now in terms of the
money that it needs to make official
budget that has come in
hundred forty nine million who knows how
accurate that actually is Hollywood
counting but that's the number that's
the official budget so let's just go
with it now a hundred forty nine million
is actually a somewhat conservative
budget in the world of superhero movies
at this point a lot of them are closer
to two hundred million or north of a
Georgia million dollar budget so this is
I don't want to say that it's a cheap
movie a more cheap superhero movie would
be Logan Deadpool those kinds of things
but this is still not quite the bloated
budget that some of the films we've
gotten lately has had so the hard and
fast dirty rule of thumb is that for a
movie to start making a profit it has to
double its production budget now again a
Hollywood accounting specifics maybe
needs to make it a little bit more than
that maybe doesn't need to make quite
that much but that's the rule of thumb
that's a hard and fast rule and right
now at 175 million opening weekend
internationally it goes look on track to
at least make its budget back so then
that's a question of how far can it go
past that in terms of being a legitimate
hit instead of merely being profitable
because that is a difference in terms of
how the executives at Warner Brothers
are going to react to this if it's just
profitable great we'll probably get a
Wonder Woman sequel they'll keep her
around as they retool other things and
get it figured out but if it's a hit if
it's a legitimate whoa that was bigger
bigger than we thought it was going to
be hit they might actually do what I
wanted them to do I wanted them to do
and what the point of my I want them the
DC EU movies to fail video was which is
that I want them to change their
approach now at the time I made that
video I did honestly believe the only
thing that was going to change their
approach was for the whole thing to just
crash and burn well I'm going to ship
that opinion and I'm now going to pin a
fair amount of hope on Wonder Woman now
one of them is not going to fix
everything because we're still going to
get Justice League in the state of
Justice League right now it's in a rough
place again even if you like PBS you
like Zack Snyder with the tragedy that
happened with him losing his daughter
which is horrible it is an absolutely
terrible thing that happened and I have
nothing but sympathy and condolences for
the man and his family now he moved off
the project Joss Whedon is now finishing
up the post for
I didn't talk about this last week
because I was traveling the videos I
uploaded last week I had recorded ahead
of time because I wasn't going to be
able to shoot anything that was a quick
reaction to what was going on so I
haven't actually talked about this
before but the just realistically a new
filmmaker coming in no matter how good
that filmmaker is and they're coming in
and they have to assemble somebody
else's work into something coherent on a
deadline that's a rough set up it's not
insurmountable but Josh Whedon
storytelling if things are not the same
exact Snider's that's not me
definitively saying one is better than
the other people have their preferences
that's fine but they are different
filmmakers the kinds of things that Joss
Whedon made you can look at serenity you
can look at the Avengers you can look at
his TV work it is very different on a
lot of levels from what Zack Snyder has
done so as much as I'm a light Joss
Whedon he doesn't seem like the most
natural fit to take the pieces that were
conceived and assembled by Zack Snyder
and put them together in a film again
that's not the Saints impossible but
even if you thought that Justice League
was on the right track which personally
I didn't and still don't that's an
awkward position to put a film in into
it's post-production so the deck is
stacked against Justice League working
now if the deck is stacked against it in
a completely different way from the way
the deck was stacked against Wonder
Woman because that was all more sort of
stigma and baggage this is the logistics
the nuts and bolts of the production and
now the post-production is may is making
it harder for Justice League to turn out
to be a good movie and personally I
don't think it will be I didn't think it
would be back when Zack Snyder was still
on it my opinion does not alter with
Joss Whedon finishing up so in my
personal opinion Justice League is lost
cause kind of was from the word go
because it was conceived and put into
motion well before the reaction to the
very divisive reaction to BBS came out
now they did say that they were trying
to make some adjustments to the film and
they're in the wake of EVF but the
shooting picked up so quickly that in my
mind yo they say Oh
make it lighter you don't have time to
restructure the script so whatever the
structure and the overall tone of the
thing that's gonna be walked in all you
can do to make it lighter is pay some
jokes over the thing and that's not
really the same thing not to mention the
fact that trying to rejigger and
reconfigure a film while you're shooting
it as opposed to getting all that sort
out before you start shooting rarely
results in a polished clean cohesive
final product so I'm sorry guys even
though Wonder Woman by all accounts is
great you know I'm not going to say you
by all accounts I'm going to say it is
great even if I end up not particularly
like it the consensus is that it's great
we'll just go with that one one being
great does not suddenly mean that
Justice League is going to be great
because the two are basically happening
almost at the same time I mean what a
woman a little bit ahead of it but they
were having kind of in parallel and
independent of each other what this
could affect would be what happens after
so we're talking
Aquaman we're talking the flash if they
ever get that thing pulled together we
were talking cyborg if that still
happens we're going into various Batman
related movies
Nightwing Batgirl the Batman all of that
if Wonder Woman is the hit that it needs
to be I'm going to say that right now it
needs to be a hit it needs to be a big
hit it needs to blow out this weekend
bigger than they're expecting and it
needs to have legs and it needs to keep
winning I will I want it to win first in
the box office three weekends in a row
that's what I want right now because the
film is the most detached from the rest
of the DC EU it's detached from all the
logistics of what has gone on in that
world it sets so far ahead in the
timeline that it's able to have its own
identity so I hope that this thing is a
hit Warner Brothers looks at it realizes
that the film that was the most
independent of everything else that
wasn't bogged down in world building but
was just telling a story saying here is
our character here is our story let's
tell the story the best that we can
because the big problems the big sort of
starting problems because there would be
later ones as the things got shot and
got Edit and whatever win both BBS and
Suicide Squad if they felt more like
world building exercises than they did
telling proper stories in and of
themselves especially Batman V Superman
by
encounter with Wonder Woman water
brothers gave patty Jenkins whatever
parameters they wanted to give her and
then they appear to have further most
parts have left her alone which is good
because they usually don't water
brothers does not leave it filmmakers
alone what they did do Suicide Squad was
completely ruined it assuming even
possibly could have been that good in
the first place I think that's debatable
and Batman V Superman I seldom seen the
ultimate cut but every fan I know and
even people who don't like them and we
still admit the ultimate cut was better
so they still force outsider to put
together something less coherent for the
theatrical release
so I'll reiterate what I said in my last
really angry rant video about the DC EU
Warner Brothers is the problem not these
individual filmmakers not this create
not these creative teams Warner Brothers
as an organization is the problem but
they listen to money
so if Wonder Woman can really nail the
box-office and Keith nail iam weekend
after weekend maybe they will look at
this and realize that what they allow
patty Jenkins to do was similar to what
they allowed Christopher Nolan do with
Batman which was to get someone who had
a vision to go in and do it now arguably
they also did that was acts nighter with
the movies that he is directed but it
may just be that the man's not a good
fit to the material what would have
thought that he would be but also one
would have thought Michael Bay would be
a good fit for transformers but somehow
things just don't click that happens
sometimes but Warner Brothers has gone
in and made it worse when they
micromanage I think again Suicide Squad
exemplifies that really amazing so if
Wonder Woman works and if then oh boy if
the Abbas command works we might finally
be on the track and and interestingly
enough it will basically be a case of
the movies that logically should have
been made before the team-up started
happening turn out being the good ones
maybe that they will start focusing
rather than everything being focused
around how big this world is now
everything is in connected instead we
just focus okay
here's the character tell this
character's story which is really what
they should have done from the beginning
and they only have
done with Man of Steel up to this point
everything else has been to cluster mess
of a ton of elements that again feel
more like rural building exercises than
proper stories or at the very least
they're trying to split the difference
between the two you need to just tell a
story that's what the audience wants we
want a good story world-building is fine
and allows you to do other things but
that can't be the point of the movie
it's the same mistake that Sony made
with the amazing spider-man 2 it was all
about setting things up for the future
movies and they told incoherent mess so
Wonder Woman is great I'm so happy for
that I'll have my proper review out
hopefully tomorrow maybe Friday morning
we'll see so you'll get my full thoughts
on the film itself but right now I just
wanted to talk if possible hopeful
positive impact on the DC EU as a whole
fingers crossed because I I would really
like to be looking forward to these
movies instead of looking at the release
schedule with a sense of dread but for
right now I'm excited to see this movie
and I didn't think I was going to be
able to say that ever and you know what
sometimes it's nice to be wrong so those
are my thoughts on the critical
reception for Wonder Woman and it's
boxed off its potential what are your
thoughts on all of this and how it might
impact the DC EU whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter and
council geeks get a listen to the
council geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]